R
WHITE HOUSE CORR LAKAITAVE S
GOUVIRSYING, TH R
RD
OWA R BN E AND WE'RE
PRESIDE NEGATIVE FOR COVID-19,?
BUT 'RORNINGT HE PH TO GO
ED.
IT'S ABOUT HOUO THE HOSPITAL
OL I ARE NOW RE THERE
WAS A PUSH THE PRESIDENT
TO ACTUALL
IT WAS SITTING O LAWN FOR AXTEN
PERIOD OF TIME, BEC
SOURCES THAT THE
PREST  T
HOSPITALIZED, DESPITEHE FACTELOS
RELATED TOOVID-19 HAD
ALREADY TAKEN EXPENTTN THE D, HS
THER NOW A ADVISERS HIM TO  BEC
BASICALLY MORE PRUDENT TOMONI T.
BUT  HOU ONE OF THE M REASO
EMLF DOESN'T WANT
HIS OWNES ORLS AND WHAT'S GOING
AND THAT COULD BE
REAS YIEFING
WTR D  WHITE HOUSE
PHYSICIANHE R ON LE  ON HICH IS
GE HAVE DIT A
QUESTION ABOUT CREDIBILITY
OF T A TIME
WHEN IT TRULYAT MO>>GIVEN TONN
ABOUT HIS ACTUA,, I
HARD TO MAK SENSE WHATHAAS REA
OBVIOUSLY,
ERE TOLD
ELYRIGHT
ABOUT U KNOW, REALL BENDING
THEMSELVNT P E DETHE OXYGEN THET
I K FEW BIG F QUESTIS,
THIS I A RESPIRATORY VIRUS.
OF IS THAT
ITLULY
ABOUT HIS KIDNEY FUNCTION, LIVEE
OXYGEN. RESPIRATORY VIRUS, BUT
I THINK THE QUESTION S IS THIS?
HASEEN
THARLOOD T T
FOR THAT, WANTO T ION  GETTING
LEVEL.
ANENT
ITNOAB
WHEN HISEGATIVE  N A POLITICAL
PEMS HISF
ILLNS, WS ON
TH
BASIC QUEST WE DON'T HAVE WER T.
>> WHEN SEAN AY, BRIEFING
T BETHESDA THAT FREE,O U>>SO
HAS  YOU THI IN
INFECTION, THAT IS A RESTHAT TH,
MEDICIO
ION PEOP WITH
ANTINF ONMPRESSION YOU'RE TRYIN,
HE HADFE FEVER
FREE FOR
NDN'T K WE CAN SAY,
BEWAS I ME BECAUSE OF K ASPI R
BUT THAT'S WHAT YOU REA ITS WAS
UPBEAT
HEICINES HE'SG OR
USTE DOWN
ON THEOIESTRICANS
THAT T PNT IS .
TRC
ITION TOLD REPORTERS
RL ANDET M PRES VITALS
RS WERE VERY AND THE HOURS WILLE
OF HIS  S
TO AL . TDE TO
NOTPANTAT THIS  BECSEOU'VE GOT
TE WO
FIIC
UPSIDE,ZERO.NOJUSIDE,T IMENTAL,B
TRAR BUTE
INATBUTANTLY,O
TORTING OLONGDHA IT Z O
CONF ON
THE  ONLYY DISTURBING ANDT
ADMISTIAL WOULD SA THE IS ON
ERY USE
SUTERMS, IT ISNTRADICTIONTHNDT S
O OUT WHEN  OUT
TODAY.
AN I T ,
AN THE IDEA
THERE'S CHAAL THISESIDENCYTHISE
IT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T MAT.YOUR WAS ANDY
POLITIY.ELY T.ESEN H  ARI THESIS
DOCTOR OUTHE , NG SCIE SPINNING
ME AND EITHER FIV
MINUTES LA YOU HIORPERSON ON TH
THEY LOOKCOMPETEN
NEITOFLF MAYBE THERE'S SOME THOA
HOT  FEBRUARY hE  DON'T WANT TOE
OPPOSI  YOU D KNOW THE THAN.ENT
UNIT SAND HEIDT WT ICK
ANS KTLEPUSTFEW MINUTES O, HE W
TO GO TO THSPITALUT THE
H IST ISHT TSAY, AS ALL OF O US
PRESIDENT, MULTIEBE NTRACTED THE
VIRUS.LLCTED AT THIS POINT,SE
SOMEFASSOCIAT A DEALING WITH
ROWOLF, IT'S KSTOUNDUST P INVOLE
WIE NOW .LLDABLYAT T AGO WHI TH
DEBATE PREP WITEENT,
WERE INSIDE SFEFRL  NOT ING MASW
VERESIDENTE PEOPLE, THE
LAHR CVEWHO WERE DOI PREPIT PREE
PRESENE PREP, WAS TH ALSO TAMPA
KELLE  PLE WHO WERESO IN THE RO
PERSON IS RSTED.
LFE REPORTED IN
THIS LATEST PIECE WE JUST CN THO
MA HAROUND THE PRESIDENTBEEN OR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TESTED POSITIVE,
STCT
HOUT W EY SHOULD BE DO
LEAINTS FROM
THEMEDIA, FROM
WHO IS DET  CONTACT TRACI M INI
FOR L AND
WHVEINTERACTEDWI N
OUTSIDE T EOTRUGGLIN
REAL INFORONOREOT ESTION T
STATUS AAPPENING W THEIR OWN
AND HOWULEHEOPOSED.
THOSE ARE QUESTIONS THAHAN FOR S
CREDIBILITY CRISIS F